back in August the Boston Globe gathered
more than 300 of its like-minded
editorial boards to scold President
Trump with his quote about his quote
frequent attacks on the media so there
will be surely a similar campaign we
believe for this gross attack on the
press I'm wondering why you won't answer
questions on the Daily Caller period
you're trash why do you think we're
trash so ok fascinating
well in case you missed it that was
Senator Bob Menendez threatening to call
the coppers on Daily Caller reporter
Henry Rogers because he didn't like the
questions being asked that reporter
Henry Rogers joins us live right now
Henry have you heard from the senator's
office or any reporters about this well
it's funny actually his communications
directors tweeted about this shortly
after it went viral after this clip went
viral after he would not speak to my
intern Paul Ingrassia and I and
threatened to call the police on us so
actually they tweeted out the article in
support of of Senator Menendez comments
yeah you know this is particularly
troubling though I mean he got
particularly hostile when he found out
that you weren't legacy media that you
were if it's you know that was the
reason why not what do you think he has
a problem with obviously conservative
media or the Daily Caller in particular
what do you think what we were broke a
story about him a couple of years ago
which led to an investigation which
basically found him guilty of hiring
underage prostitutes so I understand why
he doesn't he might not like you us our
daily caller that much but that's no
reason for him to threaten to call the
police on me for asking a fair question
a softball question yeah about the green
new deal yeah Henry absolutely I agree
with you I don't he wasn't I don't
believe he was found guilty I think that
there was a hung jury and they dropped
charges ultimately but bottom line is he
didn't like questions being asked and
he's the lawmaker threatening to call
the cops on a reporter certainly a
little bit of hypocrisy there Henry
thank you very much I want to point out
for all of you in fact the media
Apocrypha in all of this said this is
the leftist media when they don't like
something that Trump says no president
in the US has done what he is doing
which is single out you know political
enemies lump them in with the media the
president United States repeatedly
calling the press the enemy of the
people
President Trump says the media are
responsible for the country's angry
political climate ignoring his own
hostile rhetoric he really hates the
news he hates us all right but when a
member of the conservative media gets
attacked well that obvious
doesn't count as much of the same
certainly as we saw in that last segment
there with Henry joining me now is
former Tennessee congressman Zach womp
and Democratic strategist Scott Levinson
Scott so why does the left only really
defend the media when of the over the
freedom of the press in general when
it's convenient for them do you see it
that way I would think you probably know
I obviously don't know but I think the
real issue is we're creating parallels
but they don't exist the issue with the
president is he's created a hostile work
environment it's a safety issue we had a
cameraman assaulted last week he's
removed press passes that kept people
from the people's house the White House
so the fact that on the president's side
we have a safety issue not just a
politician not wanting to answer
questions that happens every we
certainly but you can say no to
answering a question without saying
you're gonna call the police on someone
you don't think that creates a security
issue or or sends a signal to Americans
that that reporter should be arrested if
they dare to ask as far as I know the
Capitol peace weren't called you they
were threatened and somebody threatened
it the halls of Congress or a public
zone and the press have a right to that
public zone the people's Housekeeping
press from the White House it's the
people's house well you can keeping
press is not to say away is not the same
as simply asking for a different
reporter to represent an entity and and
I understand what you're saying but I
think that the president's powerful as
senators powerful is equity here what do
you what's your take on this so what
what's good for the goose is obviously
not good for the gander but on the big
issue here and the reason the president
can get away with saying fake news
remember Walter Cronkite said that the
media is actually the fourth branch of
the federal government mm-hmm that
scares a lot of Americans who gave them
that kind of power it's an important
role though it is an important it's an
important role and when they have
abdicated their their job it negatively
affects our the median journalism is not
done without fear without favor and
stays objective they lose credibility
they've lost so much credibility that
the president can say fake news and it
resonates with the Americans act that is
why I wanted to distinguish between the
credibility of the news and this
safety environment yellow journalism
listed for since the 1890s in this
country people have critiqued the
credibility of the media yeah but when
you start to put the press in danger
when they start to have to be in fear of
doing their job that's when you have but
this becomes a difference also between
the president issuing an opinion of his
of the media that it is the enemy of the
people or that it's fake that's an
opinion it I would argue also if the
president came out and said a reporter
should be arrested for asking him a
question he doesn't like was it an
assault of a cameraman at a rally with
the president last week an assault so if
he's encouraging this type of aggression
towards the news reporters after they
possibly I think I think it's a bit
specious to suggest that what the
president saying considering what the
media says about Trump supporters what
the media says every single day what
Americans hear I mean the media is out
there to be heard by all Americans to
suggest that somebody who with in an
encounter in exchange with a with a
cameraman but that's the president's
fault that's one of the problems here is
that not everything is president Trump's
fault you know this is I think why
people begin to have a question about
the veracity of media and their attitude
and what they're trying to promote tami
we have a trust problem the Congress
needs to restore their trust problem
frankly senator Menendez needs to
restore his trust problem and the media
needs to restore their trust problem and
then the country would actually have
more trust more faith and and we're
seeing it also affected in the ratings
right you've you've got networks that
are being beaten by ancient aliens
because they're not trusted so much
right if people don't necessarily need
to agree with everything they hear they
want to know why you're saying it's get
some background so that they can make up
their own mind about the nature of
what's occurring and we can't conflate
having an opinion with with our
suggesting or threatening to have
someone arrested I mean that is and when
you actually could do it in the Senate
you would agree that that was an
inappropriate thing to say to to to that
reporter I mean again I don't know that
the cow please for even called in this
case but it would be like are you going
in and threatening to kill someone but
it's like I didn't
even though I threatened our violence we
sweat it but in this country we should
be able to disagree without being
enemies well we used to be able to do
that we'll get back to that at some
point I do believe all right gentlemen
thank you very much for joining me